Das Schöne an dem Beruf den ich habe, ist,
dass man hier ein einmaliges Bauwerk hat
und dass man hier ’ne tolle Übersicht hat.
Also hier in dieser Höhe ist man nicht sehr oft.
Die Technik ist hier anders, alles einmalig,
und das ist schon sehr spannend.
368 Meter hoch, mehr als 30.000 Tonnen
schwer und von fast überall in der Stadt zu
sehen: Das ist der Berliner Fernsehturm. Ein
Wahrzeichen und ein Publikumsmagnet
60 Millionen Besucher hatte der Berliner
Fernsehturm
seit seiner Eröffnung am 3. Oktober 1969.
Schon etwas unheimlich, ich dachte nicht,
dass es so hoch ist.
Wir haben Orte gesucht,
die wir besuchen können,
und den Fernsehturm
haben wir als Erstes gesehen.
Man sieht jede Sehenswürdigkeit Berlins
mit einem Blick.
Wir sind als Touristen in Berlin, und da muss
man einfach auf den Fernsehturm gehen.
Zwei Aufzüge bringen die Turmbesucher
in 40 Sekunden nach oben.
Wer mag, kann jetzt mal hoch
in den Schacht schauen.
Mit 21 Kilometern pro Stunde geht es zur
Aussichtsetage in 203 Metern Höhe.
Ist einfach ’ne sehr interessante Arbeit.
Wir haben Besucher aus der ganzen Welt,
jeden Tag neue Gäste,
die sich das Berliner Wahrzeichen
anschauen möchten.
Maximal 350 Personen gleichzeitig dürfen
aus Sicherheitsgründen hier oben sein.
Bei gutem Wetter können sie
bis zu 80 Kilometer weit sehen.
Im Restaurant eine drehbare
Aussichtsplattform:
Die Gäste fahren
während ihrer Mahlzeit im Kreis.
Man kommt hier rein,die Tische
bewegen sich, man fängt erst mal an,
seinen Tisch zu suchen.
Und man ist erst mal verblüfft von der
Aussicht, die … die einen hier oben erwartet.
Und ja, das ist schon was Besonderes halt,
ne?
Also, wenn man hier hochkommt, gibt’s schon
den Wow-Effekt.
1965: Baubeginn. Und nach nur vier Jahren
ist der Fernsehturm fertig –
im geteilten Deutschland ein
Prestigeobjekt der DDR-Führung.
Heute Wahrzeichen des wiedervereinigten
Landes und seiner Hauptstadt.
Torsten Brinkmann arbeitet seit 1994 hier und
kommt dahin, wo sonst niemand hinkommt.
Von der Antennenplattform in
246 Metern Höhe
gibt es eine einmalige Aussicht über Berlin.
Bis heute ist der Turm eine wichtige
Funkanlage für Fernsehen und Radio.
Ich finde ihn auch architektonisch gelungen
und vor allen Dingen ’ne sehr schöne, ’ne
sehr wertvolle Ingenieursleistung.
Also, was die Kollegen sich hier damals
ausgedacht haben, mit Rechenschieber und
und Tafelwerk sozusagen,
ist doch aller …, aller … sehr bemerkenswert.
Der Berliner Fernsehturm:
Nicht nur ein Touristenmagnet,
sondern ein Bauwerk,
das von der Teilung Deutschlands und seiner
Wiedervereinigung erzählt.